this is fire pong also known as rule
zero which is a project that we made for
EMF camp 2016 and the basic idea is it's
like a game of pong or one-dimensional
game of pong but with fire rather than
pixels rules are over hack spaces do not
be on fire and that basically means look
after your own safety and look after the
safety of other people around you rule 0
the game has an asterisk next to it
which basically says what the guideline
each league players I was one of these
bats you'd get timing quite right in
order to bounce a flame back to the
other end if you don't get time right
then the big buffer goes off first one
two three
so first player is randomized
oh that's its first layer alternates now
you've won I won the match by getting
first person to three points and as a
reward I get a victory swipe which means
I can whacked my bat and then lots of
fire happens that is the most fun bit in
the bats wiimotes
they're just and so many ously taped in
so as you swing the bat the Wiimote
sends a signal to roughly pi that's in
the control box which is putting in the
greenhouse at the moment this is the
main control box which has the PI in it
it has a 12 volt power supply which runs
everything and it has some rs-485 serial
controllers and a bunch of relays and
stuff all of this goes out through these
connectors to various other parts of the
system and they're all controlled using
arduino z' so we've got a whole bunch of
arduino pro mini x' quite a few of which
died in the making of this project and
they receive serial data from the
Raspberry Pi and convert it into some
sort of events that they're supposed to
do so we have display event which can
make things appear on the display panel
so this is a matrix display which was
made by another hack space member
alyttle and it just receives an rs-485
packet in a proprietary protocol that I
wrote and display some text so the PI
controls the kind of high-level stuff
and then all the individual devices
actually do the sort of turning on and
off the solenoids and Sparks and things
like that in one of these little control
boxes you can see a I've been o pro mini
there and it's connected to this
solenoid control board that's the RS 45
level
and the Arduino just turns on nathi
solenoids which will in turn make some
sparks happen and gas came out one of
the things we had to work out how to do
was how to light the gas so we
experiment with things like barbeque
lighters but they weren't really that
effective and I came across these things
one-pound 64 from eBay they put 5 volts
in you get a few thousand volts out and
then another challenge we had was how to
design a spark gap we need we need some
insulators so we've got a couple of
ceramic tubes from fuses with the screws
in the ends and a machined aluminium
block would just mounts to the right
position it was a bit of description
about what would happen when you one
wasn't there so that was when the
victory swipe came was ensue to faster
to encourage people to want to want to
win and to have that extra go and make
more fire when you win yay initially it
was just kind of if you lost then there
was a big puff but yeah we realized that
would be an incentive to just miss so
you got more fire so the victory swipe
was a kind of an incentive to actually
try to win the game and it really worked
I mean people yeah people really enjoyed
the victory swipe I think the other two
canisters are actually butane cylinders
which were discarded and they act kind
of like a gas capacitor the cool
accumulators and they store gas close to
where it comes out so that it can come
out quickly